il s'agit ici d'un roman est l'auteur a
bien voulu accepter d'en parler avec
nous voici venir
diane ducret diane ducret la dictatrice
aux éditions flammarion alors ça
rappelle évidemment le souvenir je le
disais en lancement de vos études sur
les femmes de dictateur est ce que ces
études ont nourri votre réflexion est
votre écriture pour ce rhum c'est vrai
que le sujet de la violence des femmes
de l'amour c'est un sujet assez
inépuisable en tout cas que j'avais pas
épuisé en deux volumes
ça date déjà d'une dizaine d'années est
en effet c'est pas c'est pas un hasard
je me suis demandé de dix ans plus tard
qu'est ce qu'elle serait devenue quels
seraient ces femmes de dictateur et si
l'essai m'avait permis d'exprimer le
passé l'histoire
le roman permet de parler du futur de
ces femmes de dictateurs ou de cette
dictatrice est vrai que depuis on a eu
beaucoup de femmes compris le pouvoir
qui sont arrivés en politique et je me
suis dit que peut-être on était mûr pour
en effet avoir la naissance d'une
idéologie totalitaire par une femme fait
totalement nouveau dans l'histoire là où
c'est d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
allez vous attirer beaucoup
d'ami e s dans les milieux féministes
parce que en fait vous montrer que c'est
pas parce qu'une femme est au pouvoir
qu'on est au contraire dans votre livre
protéger des dérives totalitaires or
c'est un peu ce qu'on nous vend en
disant si on confiait le pouvoir aux
femmes se seraient à pouvoir d'une
nature différente c'est pas du tout ce
qui se passe dans le livre oui c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours eu en moi j'ai
toujours entendu cet adage le monde sera
en paix quand enfin les femmes le
gouvernement en est on vraiment sûr je
travaille lentement dit l'adage
contraire j'entends d'ici les femmes
étaient au pouvoir il y aurait plus de
guerre il y aurait que des pays qui se
ferait la gueule ce qui revient un peu à
la même chose faire la gueule c'est déjà
mieux que ce faire la guerre quelque
part donc ouais finalement moi j'ai en
tout cas j'ai eu envie de mettre en
question de questionner se comprend
books on nous vend pour une certitude en
me disant que si la femme est l'égalé de
l'homme et bien elle doit l'être
absolument dans tout en tous points
c'est à dire aussi dans la
dégueulasserie aussi dans la capacité de
faire naître ou d'accoucher justement
puisqu'elle donne la vie de donner la
vie à quelque chose qui est très
mortifère qui peut être violent et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui en tout cas à
l'époque qui est beaucoup plus
radicalisés beaucoup plus radicales
qu'elles ne l'étaient il ya encore vingt
ans peut permettre oui cela en tout cas
c'est une vraie question du féminisme
ouais c'est vrai que j'ai pas que des
copines dans le mouvement mais je trouve
que là encore - ouais mais la pause et
c'est au contraire salutaire pour les
femmes pourquoi on devrait toujours être
meilleur parce qu'on donne la vie
pourquoi on devrait être la femme la
plus doux la femme douce protectrice
parce que c'est la femme mère c'est ce
qui a valu à la femme d'être toujours
ramené à sa biologie et aux côtes et
maternante sa personne c'est ce qui a
entravé sa liberté pendant bien
longtemps donc après tout moi je suis
d'accord avec vous mais vous allez vous
faire des ennemis pas seulement dans le
milieu des féminismes et dans d'autres
parce que votre dictatrice or henri elle
n'est exactement cent ans après terre
d'ailleurs née elle à strasbourg mais sa
dictature par de bonnes intentions il ya
le féminisme il ya aussi l'écologie est
ce que vous pensez que des choses qui
sont pas discutables en soi sont
porteuses de dérive autoritaire
est ce que c'est le cas pour vous du
féminisme et de l'écologie je vous pose
la question brutalement puisque c'est
quand même une des thèses du niveau vous
aimez bien oui seulement public c'est
bien ça le problème c'est que justement
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
donc on le sait mais pour être plus
précis évidemment elle a horreur henry
arrive au pouvoir avec des intentions à
ses lois
elle arrive au pouvoir comment c'est une
jeune femme qui est une journaliste de
guerre une ancienne journaliste de
guerre qui a vu la violence qui était
réservé à des contrées lointaines
arrivaient peu à peu chez nous les armes
la violence des mots mais donald trump
le sens des mots la vérité être
complètement désincarné désossé
l'impression pour beaucoup que l'europe
qui nous avait protégé devient
finalement ce qui nous force à vivre
avec autrui avec ses voisins dont on ne
veut pas ce qui nous spolient ce qui
nous impose des choses
et finalement je l'écris à 2 1 mais il
n'y avait pas encore les gilet jaune
mais ça commence dans un climat pré
insurrectionnel de manifestations ou sur
tous les week-ends dans les capitales
européennes les populistes rennes le
pouvoir les nationalistes aussi on
s'écharpe où on se bat où la violence
policière et la violence des
manifestants se rencontrent et se cogne
elle va prendre cette une pierre qu'elle
va balancer au visage d'un des
présidents comme je crois on a peut-être
en quand on est très nombreux avoir
cette envie de faire faut quelque chose
s'arrête j'ai envie de faire quelque
chose mais je ne sais pas quoi et son
envie c'est le tueur chialer porte pas
chance avec en prison après ça alors oui
absolument mais son envie en tout cas
c'est quoi un monde plus féministe un
monde plus égalitaire un monde plus
écologiste plus harmonieux entre d'entre
les hommes entre eux entre les hommes et
les femmes entre l'homme et la nature
c'est plutôt souhaitable mais
malheureusement oui toute idéologie
toute idée dès lors qu'elle vient
idéologique dès lors qu'elle est imposée
par la coercition et par un système
elle peut devenir absolument totalité
elle peut d'abord privés de liberté le
communisme à la base dans le marxisme et
nine
il ya de très belles choses très très
belles dents dans l'idée de départ c'est
là dans l'exercice ou en revanche
derrière d'un problème de votre livre
alors la parole va être aux émeutes qui
critique maintenant la prévention par
thiery moi j'avais je vais surtout une
question c'est que comme vous le dites
vous l'avez écrit à deux ans et je
trouve que en termes de politique au
sens large
la fiction est toujours en deçà d'une
réalité depuis deux ans l'air que on
voit bien avec strumpf chaque jour c'est
quelque chose dira dans une fiction
c'est impossible que très existe tout ce
qui se passe en font tout ce qui se
passe ailleurs
est-ce qu'il ya pas un côté une course
en avons finalement perdu d'avancé
à vouloir essayer de fictionné quelque
chose la réalité sera toujours plus
forte que ce que vous écrivez
j'espère qu'elle sera pas plus forte que
ce livre parce que figurez-vous que vu
ce qui s'y passe c'est vrai que l'on
disait avec eric on est 100 ans jour
pour jour après après hitler dont elle
est un peu comme un double féminin
si vous me dites que la réalité plus
forte que ça le souci c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de discours d'un roi henry qui
sont très inspirés voire même parfois
qu'ils reprennent in extenso des
discours d'adolphe hitler auquel j'ai
changé quelques mots les premiers
retours de lecture c'est à enfin
quelqu'un qui a compris ce qui se passe
en europe enfin quelqu'un qui nous
faudrait donc je peux vous dire que
j'espère vraiment que ça restera une
fiction et jamais un programme qui se
réalisera way sera très attentif à ça et
moi yann est ce que vous avez considéré
que c'était un livre qui pouvaient se
scénarise et pour faire un film parce
qu'on a l'impression quand même que
c'est très cinématographique plus que
littéraire est-ce que même on pourrait
considérer qu'ils aient une série aller
chercher à l'intérieur on n'a pas l'air
d'être un compliment n'ont plus de sens
je vais je sais pas du tout mon genre de
littérature c'est de penser un peu ce
que vous irène frain dans les années 80
90 mais est ce que vous l'avez lu celui
ci parce que des fois qu'on s'est
rencontrés vous avez fait une très belle
critique de mon dieu c'est dégueulasse
sans l'avoir lu ce que faisaient leurs
amis donc du coup si vous l'avez lu ch
on continue six pages préfère peut-être
passer à autre chose parce que du coup
ça va très bien dans les scieries c'est
qu'on est pas obligé de regarder tous
les épisodes sur ma question d'accord
donc il ne l'a pas lu une fois de casser
à la suivante du coup est ce que est ce
que vous avez quand vous écrivez vous
pensez à la scénarisation du roman ou
pas la question reste valable
la question reste au vannes oc mais
j'adore ce compliment et je serais ravi
qu en effet ça devienne une série ou un
film ça donnera l'occasion à ceux qui
n'ont quand la flemme de lire peut-être
de regarder d'en profiter
voyez maintenant le le sens de ma
question il ya autre chose moi qui me
vient à l'esprit et je corrige un peu ce
qu'a dit thierry c'est que votre livre
paraît au moment où il ya un débat que
moi qui me paraît un peu baroque en
france pour voir si on vit dans une
dictature ou pas il s'avère que j'ai
vécu deux ans dans une dictature dont je
connais un peu la différence
et puis quand vous faites des sondages
vous demandez aux gens est ce que
voulaient un pouvoir fort mais vraiment
très fortes à dire dictatorial il ya une
proportion non négligeable qui dit oui
c'est ça qu'il nous faudrait quand même
donc votre livre arrive un peu à pic
certes sur le plan fonctionnel mais pour
capter un état d'esprit du pays ça
transmet quelque chose mais pas que du
pays et c'est ça le problème c'est de
l'europe parce qu'elle va devenir
chancelière et prendre le pouvoir non
pas qu'en france mais en europe
quand vous voyez en effet
l'allemagne d'après merkel là où
longtemps quand vous voyez en autriche
la tentation qu'il y a eu en pologne
la tentation d'un pouvoir très fort pour
pacifier et réunifiée des régions c'est
actuellement assez assez radical est en
effet qu'est ce qui va porter aux nues
la dictatrice aurore henry qui
finalement après avoir jeter sept
pierres finalement devient la star des
réseaux sociaux c'est justement ces
médias et ses réseaux sociaux qui vont
en faire une icône une idole mais c'est
surtout la jeunesse qui en effet a
besoin de sens d'exemplarité et qui peut
être est intéressé par les extrêmes
parce que justement elle ne s'est pas
brûler et parmi les thèmes de réflexion
il faut imaginer adolf hitler avec les
réseaux sociaux ce qui n'est pas les
réseaux sociaux c'est qu'est ce que ça
aurait donné sursis j'ai lu votre livre
jusqu'au bout merci et pour moi c'est
avant tout l'histoire d'une femme
blessée c'est à dire que elle est
conditionnée par son histoire
personnelle
elle a été c'est une femme qui est née
sous x qui a été abandonnée qui a été
recueilli dans une famille où
effectivement ses parents adoptifs se
sont pas bien occupé d'elle d'ailleurs
quand elle est en détention elle reçoit
0 lettres de sa mère et elle explique
que finalement elle est la fille de
personne et c'est quelque chose qui
rentrent en résonance avec votre propre
histoire puisque j'ai cru comprendre que
vous aviez une maman qui avait une vie
un peu chaotique qui s'était prostituée
qui vous a laissé en garde à vos grands
parents
vous me parlez aussi de la montée de
l'islamisme et votre pape apparemment
c'est aussi converti et radicalisée est
en fait en lisant votre livre je me suis
dit en fait je suis absolument convaincu
que l'abandon génère une rage et une
colère qui finalement prédispose à faire
de l'éradication de l'injustice un
combat est ce que vous pensez de
s'acheter géologique mais ce que
j'aimerais c'est une très belle lecture
que vous en faites parce qu'un effet bon
là on parle du contexte politique parce
qu'il est il à chaud dans l'actualité
mais oui d'ailleurs alors sans s'en
faire de psychologisme qui excuserait
tout toute violence politique mais c'est
vrai quand on étudie les dictateurs il
ya toujours toujours une espèce de stein
une faille une véritable faille c'est
vrai que je l' ai beaucoup de nourri de
mon histoire personnelle puisque j'ai
été adopté par mes grands parents très
jeune et retiré à mes deux parents
oui c'est une femme blessée qui va
chercher en tout cas sa mère toute sa
vie dans sa va être l'obsession première
sa mère qui elle
faisait partie plutôt de la grande
russie on va dire donc on a deux
systèmes presque totalitaire qui
s'opposent entre le communisme et le
souvenir du nazisme qui se dessine en
creux et ça va vraiment être finalement
pour moi c'est pas tant un livre sur la
violence que sur l'amour en tout cas le
en creux la page et que l'amour et la
violence qu'il peut déclencher
ouais c'est fini le tour de taille
critique avec catherine question qui
prolonge un petit peu mais différemment
celle de sophie je suis mauvais d'où
venait cette obsession eiic tateurs des
femmes de dictateurs délicate risque que
vous aviez est ce que c'est parce que
vous avez été martyrisé au moment de
notre enfance est ce que c'est un
fantasme sexuel ou est ce que c'est le
goût l'uniforme ou de l' envie d'être
chez pas un parti autoritaire alors
obsession le terme est peut-être un peu
fort c'est vrai que le précédent d'un
livre que j'avais dédié à ce sujet la
date d'il ya dix ans dont c'est vrai
qu'entre temps j'ai fait pas mal
d'autres d'autres choses mais enfin il
ya comme toujours quelque chose c'est le
sujet féminin la femme dans l'exercice
difficile de la liberté oui face à la
violence face à l'amour aussi parfois
poussé à son extrême dans femmes de
dictateur dans son absence comme ici je
trouve que c'est oui évidemment le
déterminant personnel il est toujours là
martyrisé non je moi je m'estime pas
avoir été martyrisé bien que j'ai eu pas
mal de traumatismes ou d'accident de
parcours mais en tout cas je refuse que
ce soit un déterminant et je refuse que
cela dicte mon travail et mon âme
puisque je vois là j'en ai fait un sujet
que l'on que l'on guérit autour duquel
on construit pas forcément dans lequel
on s'enterre où l'on s'enfonce un
fantasme sexuel pas vraiment quoi que la
question est assez à propos parce qu'en
effet il ya une scène raconte rien
autres teasers il ya quelques scènes
d'un livre avec un personnage qui
s'appelle le maître de l'est qui est au
pouvoir en russie depuis plus de vingt
ans donc on aura compris vu que ça se
passe en 2023 il est très inspirée de
quelqu'un qui est au pouvoir il ya une
semaine plusieurs scènes de sexe avec
cet homme assez assez cru assène en
prison aussi de sexe un peu cru vous
allez un peu fort elles sont pas
vraiment en prison elles sont dans les
coulisses de l'opéra qui devient la
chancellerie le palais garnier devient
la chancellerie et en effet il y à il ya
ce lac sous l'opéra gars génial que les
ventes sur internet son temps
beaucoup ya ceux il ya ce lac décrit
évidemment dans le fantôme de l'opéra
et en effet il ya une scène disons que
aurore henry en fait c'est la vraie
question c'est dans dans le pouvoir
c'est cette phrase d'un wiki singer le
pouvoir absolu corrompt absolument
il ya toujours chez les dictateurs une
sorte du bri sexuelles sur de
dépravation sexuelle ou d'impôts c'est
de désir de possession de l'audi a4 au
10e je me suis demandé si au féminin on
aurait la même paire versité la même
paire version et commence à s'exprimer
scherer henry il ya cette idée de
devenir la plante la mandragore qui boit
la semence de ces prisonniers donc c'est
très game of thrones les scènes de sexe
et mature et très bon la cité pour moi
c'est l'héroïne c'est dan harris
terrienne c'est à dire que elle est
effectivement mu au départ de très
bonnes intentions et elle devient un jeu
passe poli il va peut-être pas encore vu
la fin mai effectivement elle devient
d'une cruauté absolue et je crois
qu'avec tous les arguments qu'on doit le
teaser qu'on fait sur votre livre je
pourrais demander quand même un
pourcentage motrices et dans les
coulisses vous abattre apparaît
directement
merci diane ducret d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je rappelle que votre roman
la dictatrice tu t'es paru aux éditions
flammarion merci infiniment merci